[Musique]
Natacha Polini bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
Youtube qui s'appelle view on voudrait
avoir votre avis sur le journalisme vous
avez créé récemment un S tank qui
s'appelle vous avez assumé la présidence
d'un S tank qui s'appelle le comité
Orwell qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire mais c'est un comité qui s'est
fondé à quelques journalistes
euh des nom parce que sur votre site
internet c'est pas très bien fait
onarrive pas à avoir accès à toutes les
informations du bord de ce s tank là
alors c'est très simple sur une idée
originale de Jean-Michel
4ps Alexandre de vequot qui est au
Figaro et au Figaro Vox Emmanuel Lévi
qui est à Marianne Franck de Dieu qui
est à l'expansion et voilà à priori la
petite équipe de départ c'était ça
Benjamin stromberger aussi et puis on a
comme ça au fur et à mesure agglutiner
les les énergies pourquoi bah parce que
au départ c'était des discussion entre
nous où nous nous disions que le
journalisme tel qu'il est pratiqué ne
nous plaisait pas que nous avions cette
sensation assez désagréable que certains
sujets ne sont jamais traités ou ne sont
pas traités comme ils devraient l'être
que il y a non pas une Chae de plomb
comme ça pu être le cas à un moment
donné vraiment je pense dans les années
90 2000 chape de plomb idéologique alors
là épouvantable les choses ont bougé
mais en tout cas qu'il y avait et qu'il
y a une façon de ne pas poser les
problèmes de ne pas les traiter qui est
la négation de l'idée qu'on se faisait
du journalisme donc nous avons euh eu
envie de réfléchir à la pratique
journalistique de réfléchir à la façon
dont les idées pouvaient être agitées
dont les informations pouvaient sortir
euh nous avons lancé un texte une une
sorte de manifeste et ce manifeste a
recueilli énormément d'écho donc à
partir énormément d'écho bah énormément
d'écho ça veut dire euh 4500 abonnés sur
votre page Facebook voilà des euh 140
abonnés sur votre page Youtube
exactement 305 vues sur votre COC
d'ouverture ouais ouai c'est il me
semble que d'arriver à
mobiliser 250 personnes dans un colloque
c'est quand même pas non
plus quelque chose de d'évident on a
reçu énormément de messages de gens nous
disant bravo merci de de réfléchir à ça
je pense que il y a aujourd'hui une
insatisfaction énorme de la part des
Français
sur ce que sont les médias il y a une
impression de ne pas être informé une
impression
que oui ouais oui réellement réellement
une forme de trahison et l'idée que les
médias jouent un rôle de chien de garde
donc je pense que N chien garde de qui
chien de garde d'un système chien de
garde de on va dire d'un système qui
pour reprendre la phrase de Warren
Buffett est une véritable lutte des
classes é sont en train de gagner euh je
pense qu'il y a de ça euh vous avez vous
avez
euh posé des questions à christineokrent
concernant les réseaux de pouvoir le
cercle bildelberg oui comment ça ça vous
est venu à l'esprit nous personnellement
on les connaît on a on a travaillé avec
certains qui ont participé au bildelberg
y compris y compris de la Commission
Trilatérale on reçoit souvent HERV
carmois qui est qui était vice-président
de la Commission Trilatérale Europe
euh ce sujet de cercle de pouvoir n'est
vraiment pas abordé ça vous est venu à
l'idée comment et la réaction qu'elle a
eu en face de vous c'était naturel
c'était comment c'était violent on va
dire je pense qu'elle s sou encore con
elle vous a pris pour une conne non
seulement elle m'a prise pour une conne
mais elle m'a prise surtout pour
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas à poser ce
genre de question et qui tout à coup
faisait surgir quelque chose qui ne doit
pas surgir euh au milieu d'un on va dire
d'un d'un débat convenu entre jambes
bien le Ron rond c'est ça mais vous
savez c'est c'est valable pour ce ce
genre de de question pour comment ça
m'est venu de parler de du réseau
builderberg parce que tout simplement
j'ai lu en travaillant sur elle qu'elle
en avait fait
partie je me suis posé la question de
savoir quelle était la place d'un
journaliste dans ce genre de cercle
qu'est-ce qu'on venait y chercher
pourquoi est-il très sain qu'un
journaliste soit dans les mêmes réseaux
de fréquentation et d'influence que des
chefs d'entreprise des des des
politiques est-ce que réellement ça lui
rapporte de l'information non il n'y a
aucun but informatif là-dedans puisque
justement le principe est que ce qui est
dit ne sorte pas donc ce n'est pas pour
aller chercher de
l'information ce n'est pas pour aller
comprendre le fonctionnement
de on va dire
des des systèmes politiques et
économiques parce que je pense qu'on
peut les comprendre parfaitement sans
cela donc est-ce que vous avez déjà
assisté à un type de de réunion de de
cette ampleur là de ce niveau-là non
honnêtement est vous êtes déjà est-ce
que vous avez déjà été dans un
cercle de ce niveau-là non non non très
honnêtement non mais je pense que je n'y
serai pas pour une raison simple c'est
que justement je ne pratique pas mon
métier de journaliste de cette façon
c'est-à-dire que je ne pense pas que la
proximité avec les hommes politiques par
exemple m'apporte quoi que ce soit dans
ma façon de traiter la les question
politique et de
réfléchir au rôle que jouent les
politiques au choix qui sont les leurs
vos collègues vos collègues le serrail
journalistique a fait corp avec vous
derrière ou vous a
laissé écoutez je pense que euh comment
vous
dire j'ai toujours été un peu à part
dans le les milieux journalistiques où
j'ai travaillé pour peut-être parce que
justement je n'ai pas un parcours de
journaliste je n'ai pas fait d'école de
journaliste moi j'ai une agrégation de
lettres alors évidemment j'ai fait
Science Po aussi mais à un moment où
j'avais déjà enseigné où j'avais j'étais
professeur donc mon parcours il est plus
à grec de lettres que que sciencep et je
j'ai continué à enseigner ensuite en
même temps que je pratiquais le
journalisme donc peut-être que ça m'a
donné une façon de de traiter les
problèmes assez
différentes on m'a parfois
reproché parmi mes collègues de trop
intellectualiser de trop éditorialiser
c'estàdire qu'en effet j'assume la
pratique d'un journalisme d'opinion que
j'ai appris à Marianne avec
Jean-François Cann qui m'a toujours
expliqué que c'est une tradition
française que ça n'a jamais dérangé
personne quand il s'agissait de jores de
clémence de tout ce qu'on veut et que
c'est une c'est une
façon de de respecter le lecteur il sait
d'où l'on parle donc pour revenir sur le
comité orwel et sur le les
journalistes il y a il y a un problème
ça c'est sûr la la question que je vous
ai posée quand j'ai été au invité au
comité Orwell c'est si le comité Orwell
c'est-à-dire ce cette prise de
conscience cette émergence de prise de
conscience de la profession ne
fonctionne pas qu'est-ce qui va passé et
je vous ai
répondu la Révolution et je le crois
profondément c'est-à-dire que je pense
que dans ce que Christopher l appelait
la sécession des élites c'est-à-dire le
fait que nous avons aujourd'hui partout
dans le monde des élites qui n'ont plus
les mêmes intérêts objectifs que les
peuples des pays auquels ils
appartiennent dans ce cadre-là si on
continue à accepter cette fracture a
laissé se déliter
les on va dire le le bien commun et la
préservation du bien commun au sein de
des nations je pense qu'on va vers des
mouvements violents je pense qu' on sent
une colère qui monte une colère qui peut
s'exprimer de façon très très diverse
personne ne sait ce qui peut se passer
mais il est évident que les élections
américaines les élections françaises
élections partout en Europe nous montre
que les peuples cherchent pour l'instant
tout de même à travers l'exercice
démocratique mais peut-être de moins en
moins à faire entendre leur voix à
reprendre le pouvoir ou en tout cas à
faire comprendre aux élites que ils se
sont aperçus qu'on leur avait qu'on leur
avait pris le pouvoir voilà qu'on les
prenait pour des compes tout simplement
oui qu'on les prenait pour des comp bah
oui mais que les intérêts que les
intérêts sont sont divergents tout
simplement et qu'on s'assi sur la dé
donc on peut pas s'asseoir sur la
démocratie très très très longtemps il y
a un moment où ça marche plus les
préconisations pour améliorer ça s'il y
a des conseils à faire passer à vos
collègues
h peut-être ma formation intellectuelle
me pousserait-elle à dire que la
première préconisation serait de lire
oui serait de développer une culture
générale une curiosité qui permet
d'avoir un tout petit peu de recul
sur les discours qui sont produits des
petits cours d'autodéfense
intellectuelle oui c'est ça c'est quand
même grave de conseiller c'est un
journaliste ils ont oublié ça la charte
de Munich il y avait eu il y a quelques
années dans Le Monde diplomatique une
enquête très intéressante sur les écoles
de journalisme oui je me je ne me
rappelle pas le nom du journaliste
brville oui oui ou oui mais il
expliquait à quel point il y avait une
chose qui manquait furieusement dans les
écoles de journalisme ce sont les Bibl
et je pense que
c'est une des dimensions importantes du
problème c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à
présent les
journalistes enfin le journalisme
n'était pas tout à fait une profession
comme les autres un jour un jour je me
suis pris la tête avec Serban
Schreber je lui objectais c'est à
l'époque de laffers àange et le
partenariat entre les maisons de presse
et WikiLeaks pour traiter les câbles et
j'étais un petit peu en train de la
sticoter sur la l'indépend des
journalistes et sa grande tirade a été
mais vous m'objectez l'indépendance des
journalistes moi durant ma longue
carrière je n'ai jamais senti la laiss
du pouvoir se tendre sur les
journalistes là on est en 2016 est-ce
qu'il y a une laisse au coup des
journalistes c'està-dire que pour ne pas
sentir la laisse se tendre il suffit pas
tirer dessus oui oui pour sentir sa
liberté mais bien sûr qu'il y a une
laisse il y a une laisse d'abord
j'allais dire simplement économique la
situation actuelle des médias fait que
les journalistes sont sous dépendance
parce qu'ils sont en permanence menacés
de perdre leur travail tout simplement
je ce qui est en train de se passer dans
le groupe de L'Express et l'expansion
c'est une saignée absolue c'est-à-dire
qu'on a des journalistes qui aujourd'hui
se retrouvent sur le carreau SAÉ ou une
épuration pour l'instant je dis une
saignée parce que je je ne sais pas
exactement quels sont les choix qui sont
à l'œuvre mais en tout cas je je pense
en effet que ça relève j'allais dire je
je serais pas forcément immédiatement
malveillante dans ma façon de prendre
les choses dans le sens où je ne pense
pas forcément qu'il y ait une épuration
idéologique parce que je crois que
malheureusement l'idéologie première
c'est l'économisme c'est-à-dire l'idée
qu'on va réduire les coûts c'est tout ça
est fait par des gens qui n'ont aucune
notion de ce qu'est une entreprise de
presse qui ne qui se foute complètement
de la spécificité du travail d'un
journaliste mais il Contin continu à
investir dedans pourtant ça perd du
fric alors il reste encore une dimension
de prestige et de poids politique dans
le fait de posséder un média même si on
perd du fric même pas seulement de
propagande même pas seulement c'est
simplement l'idée que l'on pèse dans son
rapport avec des politiques et avec
d'autres milieux économiques ivent d'une
chaîne Youtube avec beaucoup d'abonnés
voilà c'est ça
exactement on a reçu deny Robert à
plusieurs reprise qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de deny
Robert écoutez
je j'aurais dû j'aurais du mal à avoir
un jugement définitif parce que c'est
quelqu'un que je n'ai jamais rencontré
j'ai suivi son travail j'ai été
intéressée par son travail
après je ne me prétendrais pas
spécialiste du sujet et j'ai horur de
parler quand quand je ne maîtrise pas
suffisamment ce ce don je parle vous AZ
pas vu son film l'enquête non je n'ai
pas vu son film l'enquête donc vous êtes
au courant de son travail quand il a
commencé à remuer un petit peu la merde
des chambre de compensation avec le
Luxembourg il s'est fait un peu lapider
par votre
corporation alors comment ça se fait
qu'il y a pas de solidarité entre les
journalistes que oh il y en a quand il
faut c'est-à-dire quandand du
oui ou quand il s'agit de d'expliquer
enfin de de de prendre des aires outré
parce que tel ou tel par exemple telle
ou telle politique dénonce justement des
journalistes euh trop proche du pouvoir
là tout à coup on a vraiment des comment
mais vous attaquez les journalistes
c'est un scandale donc non non il y a
une il y a un corporatisme évident mais
en effet il joue pas forcément là où il
devrait sur alors on va on va on va
prendre un dossier un peu plus frais euh
Paul Mora sur l'Ukraine s'est fait
ramasser un peu sur les réseaux sociaux
côté journaliste c'est fait aduler par
une grande partie de l'Internet par
rapport à son indépendance
d'esprit pour ceux qui ont vu son
documentaire votre avis là dedans en
tant que présidente du comité Rowel
est-ce qu'on a le droit de traiter tous
les sujets ah il est évident qu'on n pas
le droit de traiter tous les sujets
c'estàd bien sûr queil y a une espèce de
on va dire
de pas de censure mais mais
de comment dire de façon très très
claire de faire sentir qu'il y a des
choses dont on ne peut pas parler et des
choses qu'il ne faut pas aller fouiller
que tout à coup on sort de ce que Al la
main qui appelle le cercle de la raison
voyez la police de la pensée oui bien
sûr bien sûr et cette cette police de la
pensée elle est extrêmement puissante
dans la mesure où il s'agit avant tout
de faire passer celui qui a débordé des
limites pour conspirationiste un
conspirationniste un incompétent un
quelqu'un donc qui ne qui tout à coup
n'a rien à faire à la table des gens
sérieux vous connaissez Arthur
Schopenhauer Arthur Schopenhauer oui
l'art d'avoir toujours raison oui bien
sûr vous avez pas l'impression que c'est
un petit peu le livre de jeevet de tous
ces intellectuels médiatiques c'est
prendre le contrôle de la dialectique
grâce à des stratagème alors à ceci près
que qu'est-ce qu'on appelle intellectuel
médiatique et qui désigneon
par là c'est-à-dire que le concept
d'intellectuel médiatique en ce moment
il est utilisé aussi pour disons comme
une arme et pour décrédibiliser certains
voyez C c'est un concept à géométrie
variable intellectuel médiatique quand
l'intellectuel médiatique c'est BHL ou
Alain min finalement ça ne dérange pas
mais en ce moment les ce qu'on appelle
intellectuel médiatique c'est ce que
Najad Valou Belkassem a appelé les
pseudos intellectuels c'est-à-dire ceux
qui qui pensent mal ceux qui ont eu le
le mauvais goût de critiquer la réforme
du collège et là tout à coup
intellectuel médiatique était une forme
de dévalorisation voyez donc c'est pour
ça que le le concept me qu'est-ce qu'on
fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour aller
récupérer cette indépendance d'esprit et
aller traiter les sujets nécessaires
pour avoir un prisme de lecture profond
on fait un syndicat de
journaliste surarmé intellectuellement
parlant on fait des groupes de pression
on fait quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour nous on a tendance un petit peu àav
votre profession ils savent pertinemment
que quand ils viennent commenter les
choses chez nous s'ils ont pas l'étoff
ou la trampe d'un Denis Robert il ils se
font
vaporiser on aimerait quand même un peu
vous aider on fait quoi nous
l'Internet on va protéger les
journalistes on fait le boulot de on
fait quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour vous aider je pense
que le travail que vous faites le
travail qui se trouve sur Internet
ne doit pas venir en aide au
journalistes c'est une alternative c'est
une autre façon de produire de
l'information et de la pensée simplement
moi j'ai une attache pour le journalisme
classique et en particulier de presse
écrite dont je pense que pour l'instant
il n'est pas encore remplacé il son son
rôle exact ne pourrait pas être être
remplacé de la presse écrite oui vous
connaissez la la capacité d'un
algorithme à agréger de l'information et
à écrire un article mais mais un
algorithme ne remplacera jamais ce que
moi je vais chercher dans de la presse
écrite à savoir non pas seulement de
l'information mais du reportage de la
pensée du jugement même voilà c'est ça
qui apporte qui est censé apporter la
presse qu'elle ne fait pas parce que le
reportage on a plus d'argent pour en
faire la pensée bah encore faut-il
pouvoir
l'articuler donc voilà c'est tout donc
je pense que il y a aujourd'hui une
forme de journalisme lowcost qui est en
train de se développer
avecalisation pardon nubérisation du
journalisme ah mais totalement
totalement il suffit de voir comment les
dans les rédactions de presse
quotidienne le modèle du numérique est
en train de dicter sa loi aux
journalistes de presse écrite de même
que les chaînes d'informationue ont
dicté leur mode de fonctionnement au
reste du journalisme c'est-à-dire que la
le temps long le recul sont en train de
disparaître ce qui compte aujourd'hui
pour un journaliste c'est de produire le
plus vite possible pour faire de
l'alerte smartphone mais même dans des
grands quotidiens nationaux voilà donc
je pense que c'est contre cela qu'il
faut lutter c'est c'est et d'ailleurs
vous avez un travail journalistique sur
le net qui arrive à lutter contre ça
mais qui pour l'instant vivote ne
serait-ce que ce matin dans marvu de prè
je citais le site ulyses qui est une
entre le journalisme et l'édition mais
qui fait du temps long qui fait de
l'enquête qui fait du récit mais il me
semble que ça c'est un modèle c'est une
des formes du journalisme qui
malheureusement est en train d'être
éradiqué des médias classiques
pourquoi question économique pas une
question de et question aussi de
capacité du public à se donner la peine
de lire j'ai j'ai interviewé le le
directeur de la télévision publique
russe en Russie bon je l'ai un peu
chauffé hein sur la liberté de la presse
sur des gens qui disparaissent oui ce
sont des choses qui arrivent ça arrive
mais bon comment se comportaient les
journalistes russes pour enquêter des
choses comme ça et puis en partant il me
dit tu sais par l'intermédiaire de son
traducteur il faut donner non pas ce que
les gens ont besoin mais ce que les gens
veulent question philosophieque ça de
savoir en France on leur donne quoi car
poer s'est posé la question de savoir
si en matière de télévision par exemple
la démocratie consistait à donner aux
gens ce qu'ils veulent et je crois que
tout cela
est moi je ne crois pas voou alors on
fait quoi pourquoi parce que mais je je
précise pourquoi parce que sans un
peuple éduqué la démocratie c'est la
tyrannie des imbéciles donc donner aux
gens ce qu'ils veulent en faisant en
sorte qu'ils ne veuillent que des choses
simples distrayantes faciles parce qu'on
les a abruti et qu'on a fait en sorte de
détruire l'outil d'éducation qui l'école
ça n'est plus de la démocratie et si on
passe le point de nos retour
d'abétissement de la population et ben
on sort de la démocratie et c'est bien
le problème et c'est bien ce qui
m'inquiète et on en est pas loin l'état
d'urgence pour vous c'est quoi l'état
d'urgence c'est une des façons
d'agiter la la M
de faire croire au bon peuple qu'on le
protège en évitant de se poser les
véritables problèmes la déchéance de
nationalité même chose ça fait quand
même un mois que les médias sont à temps
plein sur une question absolument
ridicule il faut que ça passe c'est tout
non maiso pourquoi il faut déchoir
quelqu'un de sa nationalité est-ce que
vous avez est-ce que vous avez étudié un
petit peu à partir de
2001 t tous les exécutive order
américain le patriotact et tout
l'arsenal législatif autour de
l'emprisonnement la torture le
kidnapping et l'assassinat est-ce que
c'est pas plus facile pour un État
français maintenant d'aller demander des
informations d'une façon un peu
plus prédatrice sur un détenu parce que
comme il sera plus protégé par notre
Constitution il aura une extra
territorialité de sa justice est-ce que
c'est pour ça que les médias sont en
train de n en faire manger pendant un
mois là c'est que après on va aller
attraper les terroristes il va fallir
les faire parler mais si on fait parler
un terroriste qui est d'origine
française on va peut-être pas pouvoir le
torturer comment on pouvait
torturer un sauvage déchu de sa
nationalité alors peut-être suis-je un
peu naïve ou peut-être suis-je beaucoup
plus pessimiste que vous sur les
journaliste je ne sais pas mais j'ai
j'ai tendance à penser que ça n'est même
pas ça le problème ah ouais oui que le
problème la raison pour laquelle les
journalistes s'agitent depuis un mois
là-dessus c'est parce que le Marigo
politicien les fascine c'est parce que
de savoir si Hollande a mis un poignard
dans le dos de Sarkozi et si la droite
va se faire triang plus B la vie
politique Santa Barbara Tov uniquement
ça ouis uniquement ils vont pas du tout
aller réfléchir aux implications réelles
là dans le journalisme classique il y a
une hiérarchie il y a une hiérarchie
implicite tout en haut il y a les
journalistes politiqu
les autres c'est le lumpen prolétariat
en particulier les journalistes sur les
questions de société et cetera pourtant
c'est le plus important or les
journalistes politiques sont euh on va
dire des commentateurs sportifs c'est
machin couru plus vite que que l'autre
c'est qui le meilleur
commentateur meilleur commentateur ça je
ne sais pas parce que justement ça
m'ennuie profondément le commentaire
sportif vous voyez donc bon
mais comment vous dire ce sont des
spécialistes de la vie politique des
partis
sauf que quand vous regardez là aussi le
fonctionnement d'une rédaction quand on
il s'agit d'aller interviewer un homme
politique en vue on se fout de savoir
quelle est sa spécialité on envoie les
journalistes politiques qui vont
évidemment être incapable de
l'interroger sur les réelles décisions
politiques qu'il prend vous savez dans
une rédaction de journal on est capable
d'aller interroger le ministre de
l'éducation national sans demander aux
journalistes spécialistes d'éducation ça
arrive c'est parce que ce qui compte
c'est que les G journaliste politique
viennent lui demander alors vous
postulez à quoi et alors quelle est
votre tactique pour battre machin et
cetera il y a que ça qui les intéresse
donc je pense aussi que enfin c'est ça
explique beaucoup du fonctionnement des
du fonctionnement des journaux vous
voyez par de là les les questions
purement idéologiques de fond c'est que
justement malheureusement il y a pas
d'idéologie il y a pas de réflexion
c'est des coqu Creus c'est ou c'est
simplement des des des put fric il cour
après le fric alors après il y a des
questions de
génération c'est-à-dire
que il y a eu toute une tradition du
Grand
journalisme politique à la française qui
d'ailleurs a bien du mal à comprendre
que la proximité avec son sujet peut
parfois être très très problématique
voilà donc mais les jeunes aujourd'hui
les jeunes journalistes ont tendance à
reproduire ça alors en étant un peu plus
mordant en étant un petit peu plus
rentre dedans
moins dans la connivance mais tout de
même ils vont alors c'est pour le coup
pêcher par absence de culture politique
absence de culture historique qui leur
interdira ne serait-ce que de faire
preuve du minimum de mémoire qui permet
d'interroger un homme politique sur ses
choix sur son parcours sur sur la
cohérence de de de ce qu'il fait est-ce
que c'est le principe de Peter appliquer
à votre
profession c'est possible c'est possible
je pense que
c'est surtout pouvez nous rappeler le
principe de Peter le principe de Peter
c'est le principe de d'incompétence
c'est ce c'est l'idée que c'est c'est
l'idée que on atteint au bout d'un
moment son seuil d'incompétence si je ne
me trompe c'est bien ça si mes souvenirs
sont mon c'est qu'on place les éléments
les plus incompétent des ha post parce
que c'est là où ils font le moins de mal
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle l'éviction
par le haut aussi que j'ai vu beaucoup
pratiquer et c'est aussi le fait
que plutôt dans ce principe il y a
l'idée que chacun va monter les échelons
jusqu'au moment où il ne pourra pas
monter parce qu'on voit qu'il a atteint
son seuil d'incompétence sauf queune
fois qu'il a atteint son seuil
d'incompétence bah il est là geoffrein
il est
incompétent est-ce que Geoffrin est
incompétent je ne dirais pas ça enfin je
n'ai jamais trouvé que les résultats
qu'il avait donné à la tête des
rédactions qu'il a dirigé était
fulgurant je en terme même de nombre de
lecteurs foyer de développement d'un
titre après euh chez Laurent Joffrin il
y a un problème idéologique là moi j'ai
du mal euh avec quelqu'un qui considère
que son travail euh est de faire en
sorte d'abord de défendre mordicus la
politique d'un président de la
République qui a trahi toutes ses
promesses de campagne et ensuite de
criminaliser tous ceux qui pourraient
éventuellement s'opposer à cela ou faire
valoir qu'il y a d'autres politiques
possibles sa façon de jeter l'E prob sur
les opinions qui le dérangent c'est ça
ben oui de traiter carrément de
cryptofasciste à peu près tout ce qui ne
rentre pas dans le cadre on va dire de
la gentille social-démocratie qui
d'ailleurs n'est même plus une
socialdémocratie mais du libéralisme pur
quand il me dit quand il me dit il y a
énormément d'informations qui passent il
y a pas de de police de la pensée il y a
pas de cyclore rien du journalisme oui
ça s'appelle se moquer du monde he vous
être déconnecté
je pense que malheureusement ce genre de
personnage arrive très sincèrement à à
se persuader de ce qu'il dit
c'est-à-dire que il est convaincu qu'il
est en lutte contre une France Rance
noséabonde parce que dans ces cas-là
vous avez remarqué qu'il y a quand même
une sensibilité olfactive assez marquée
hein chez ces gens-là c'est toujours les
adjectifs olfactifs qui pr qui prévalent
et
donc je pense qu'il est
intimement convaincu d'être dans le camp
du Bien face au
salot vraiment et que il fait œuvre de
salubrité publique en essayant à tout
prix d'empêcher que puisse surgir une
alternative ne comprenant pas évidemment
que sa façon de renvoyer au Front
national toute personne qui ne pense pas
exactement dans la ligne libérale qui
est la sienne bah laisse justement le
monopole de l'alterna politique au Front
national mais après tout c'est c'est ce
qui est recherché je pense c'est l'idée
que on va P que on a besoin d'un diable
on va pouvoir agiter ce diable et tant
qu'il existe on continue soi-même à
exister on va passer sur la politique
étrangère la France qui va intervenir un
peu partout la France qui a plus
beaucoup de sous des terroristes qui
frappent maintenant sur le territoire
une politique étrangère sans aucune
remise en
question non seulement sans aucune
remise en question mais qui poursuit
depuis des années maintenant un
alignement sur les États-Unis qui est la
négation absolue de tout ce qu'avait été
sa tradition diplomatique et qui le fait
en plus pour les pires raisons qu'il
soit tout simplement parce qu'il y a
plus d'argent et parce que du coup on
pense qu'il faut aller prendre les
capitaux là où ils sont c'est-à-dire en
Arabie Saoudite et au Qatar je crois
très sincèrement que notre diplomatie
est dictée par notre besoin d'argent et
que pour faire illusion ensuite on
s'invente des guerres un peu
partout en nayant pas d'ailleurs les
moyens suffisant pour les pour pour les
mener dans la mesure où le budget
militaire a été réduit de façon
ahurissante r mais nettoyer nettoyer
mais comme la posture du chef de guerre
ça marche encore en France et que ça
permet de gagner des points dans les
sondages tout à coup on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas mal
l'armée si vous aviez à vous positionner
dans cette phrase c'est à ces politiques
qui leur crèvent les yeux ou à ces
fouaveugles redites-moi la phrase je
sais pas à ces politiques qui leur
crèvent les yeux ou à ses foules
aveugles euh si j'interprète bien la
phrase il s'agit de savoir si c'est la
responsabilité des des politiques ou si
c'est de la responsabilité des gens qui
acceptent je pense que c'est un jeu en
miroir je pense
que les foules aveugles en effet ont
accepté depuis des années de se
dessaisir du pouvoir que leur avait
donné la démocratie c'est du
misérabilisme de l' puissance
c'est une forme
de on va dire de paress de paresse
entretenu par tout un système
c'est-à-dire que je pense que le
principe de la société de consommation
et de spectacle évidemment de
d'encourager cette paresse de la faire
prospérer de de développer chez les gens
les pulsions
immédiates oui oui oui bien sûr le le
principe même de la consommation euh à
travers incité par la publicité c'est ça
c'est de jouer sur les pulsions en les
en activant des stimulis pour justement
éviter toute toute réflexion tout recul
on est dans la manipulation pure
quand quand Patrick Lelay explique que
son métier consiste à vendre à Coca-Cola
du temps de cerveau humain disponible il
a résumé le fonction
de la démocratie aujourd'hui les gens
sont
cons on les a rendu con on fait en sorte
qu'ils soient cons moi j'ai énormément
j'ai une très très grande un très très
grand respect pour les
savoirs non scolaires les savoirs non
universitaires et je pense qu'il y a que
l'humanité a développé ses savoir
pendant des siècles de façon admirable
j'entendais l'autre jour une rediffusion
des très vieux extraits de bonjour
Monsieur le Maire de Pierre bon ça
paraît totalement ringard il allait dans
le fin fond de la France paysane dans
les années 60 et il interrogeait des
gens dont on comprenait qu'ils avaient
une intelligence et une masse de culture
absolument énorme énorme c'est une
culture qui a été éradiquée qui a été
éradiquée par quoi par un triptique
télévision publicité grande
distribution ce qui a petit à petit euh
engluer ses gens chez eux devant leur
télé en rompant tous les liens sociaux
qu'ils pouvaient avoir avec le monde qui
les entourit et qui les a incité à rêver
de ce qu'ils allaient pouvoir trouver le
samedi au
supermarché je pense qu'il y a là une
une aliénation absolument
monstrueuse c'est cette catatonie
émotionnelle créé dans la population par
cette cette anesthésie qui est la la
presse ce ch ce cirque crée maintenant
une incompréhension entre les flux de
migrants la douleur des migrants la
souffrance des
migrants ça va se matérialiser comment
quand les gens vont commencer à prendre
conscience de la réalité de des
souffrances mondiales qui se déplace qui
s'est mis en en ordre de marche ça peut
être extrêmement dangereux ça peut ça
peut être extrêmement dangereux parce
que tout cela n'est absolument pas pensé
ou préparé parce que le stabilo doué
exercice Suisse à partir de 2012
fermeture intégrale du territoire de ses
frontières contre un influx massif de
migrants provenant d'Espagne d'Italie de
Grèce de
France les militaires réfléchissent
quand même à ça
oui mais je pense que les politiques ne
réfléchissent pas je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de réflexion politique sur ce
qu'implique des déplacement de
population qui ont été en grande partie
causé par des
décisions occidentales absolument
délirante je nous sommes en train quand
même de payer la guerre d'Irak la guerre
de Libye qui ont déstabiliser totalement
des pays et dans une irresponsabilité
totale donc
aujourd'hui cette souffrance
provoquée va déstabiliser mécaniquement
les sociétés européennes et tout cela
n'est absolument pas anticipé vous
croyez à la balcanisation de l'Europe
oui je le je le crains je crains qu'il y
ait un éclatement total des nations et
des des lutte violent parce que on voit
monter la violence aujourd'hui on voit
que dans dans l'ensemble des pays
européens il y a des
radicalisations de toutes part chaque
chaque camp
idéologique ethnique se
radicalise et montre de moins en moins
d'empathie de moins en moins de capacité
à penser les choses
politiquement donc je crains énormément
que dans l'avenir il puisse y avoir des
véritablement
des des éruptions de viol on sait très
bien l'histoire nous montre qu'une
société sensément civilisée peut
basculer dans la barbarie extrêmement
rapidement jusque là tout va
bien écoutez moi je ne pense pas que
tout aille bien mais tant qu'on a des
dirigents qui se rassurent en
s'imaginant qu'il sen'entiront et en ne
réfléchissant pas plus plus loin qu'à un
ou de mois ou au mieux à l'élection
suivante ça continuera mais très
honnêtement je pense que c'est c'est
pour ça que notre responsabilité
notamment en tant que journaliste est
d'essayer de penser le temps long c'est
d'essayer justement de décrypter des
mouvements qui sont des mouvements
intellectuels des mouvements de pensée
des mouvements de d'opinion bien plus
vastes mais pour ça ça nécessite d'abord
de prendre le temps de réfléchir ça
nécessite aussi la culture suffisante
justement pour être capable de faire le
lien entre les événements on va changer
de sujet Edward snowon ça vous fait
penser à
quoi
HM comment vous dire à quoi ça me fait
penser
euh ça me fait penser d'abord à une
forme de lâcheté terrible de la France
ça oui dans la façon dont tu as été
géré
son enfin dans le dans la façon dont la
France a refusé
euh de lui venir en aide l'asile euh oui
oui oui
h que vous dire de plus
euh la
NSA je pense que nous avons totalement
renoncé à faire prévaloir
euh on va dire une indépendance toi en
tant que journaliste tu fais comment
pour vous faites comment pour protéger
vos sources la cast journalistique ne
sait pas chiffrer ses mails la cas
journalistique une connaissance
parcellaire ou voir vaporisée de du
milieu numérique euh j'ai beau discuter
avec eux et leur expliquer que la
confidentialité d'une enquête c'est
important que vous pouvez mettre en
danger toute une salle de rédaction avec
une demi-clé USB ils sont complètement à
l'Ouest c'est est-ce qu'il y a des cours
je connais je connais deux journalistes
dans le numérique qui font correctement
leur boulot et on le on leur manifeste
notre respect Jean-Marc Manac qui est
Marc rise il y en a d'autres mais c'est
de là essayent de prêcher un petit peu
euh leurs confrères
euh c'est vous savez chiffrer un mail
non bien sûr mais vous savez moi je suis
pas je suis pas une journaliste
d'investigation non mais vous êtes
présidente d'un S tank maintenant c'est
vrai et donc en effet je pense que quand
on est journaliste d'investigation il y
a ce genre de précaution à prendre mais
je vais être très honnête avec vous moi
ma pratique journalistique elle est d'un
autre ordre c'estàd que il y a
différentes formes de journalisme je je
n'incarne pas le journalisme
d'investigation moi je suis quelqu'un
qui essae de on va dire de penser le
monde tout simplement et de d'en
décrypter
les les mouvements idéologiques alors
snowon c'est quoi c'est un mouvement
idéologique c'est la la réminiscence de
l'affaire farwell mais côté américain
cette fois-ci
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est oui c'est la
c'est la
révélation absolue d'une forme
d'impérialisme extrêmement puissant et
extrêmement
violent
d'une on va dire du d'un rouleau
compresseur malgré tout sous les
apparences des bonir
d'une va dire d'une d'une puissance en
tant de paix mais il n'y a pas de paix
on a on a récemment interviewé le le le
le ministre conseiller de l'ambassade de
Russie puis juste après son patron
l'ambassadeur Alexandre Orlof
ambassadeur de la Fédération de Russie
bon comme on est un peu taquin on a
appelé les Américains derrière on leur a
proposé le même deal avec les les mêmes
choses et on s'est rendu compte que pour
avoir une une interview de
l'ambassadrice américaine c'était déjà
10 minutes
maximum et qu'il fallait c'était mieux
d'envoyer les questions juste avant
euh quand on leur a dit qu'on venait de
YouTube et qu'on procédait pas comme ça
que toutes les interactions qu'on allait
avoir avec eux allent être publi ils ont
commencé à tousser comment ça se fait
que les journalistes acceptent d'aller
je vais pas dire [__] parce que
donner ses questions avant c'est c'est
[__] non c'est quoi alors c'est
compliqué et ça dépend ça dépend dans
dans quel cadre et puis ça ça dépend si
c'est toutes les questions que vous
donnez et si ça interdit les relances
après vous voyez c'est-à-dire est-ce que
j'ai déjà eu à donner mes questions
avant non jamais mais en tout cas pas en
télé un thème quoi vous donnerz les axes
genre nous on dit géopolitique internet
finances terrorisme plus pas plus pas
plus
euh donner les questions avant ce enfin
comment vous dire
[Musique]
euh non j'essaie j'essaie de me de
réfléchir à comment on peut biaiser face
à ça parce que qu'une ambassadrice
américaine réclame qu'on lui donne les
questions avant ça ne me surprend pas
réclame pas c'est préfér c'est
préférable oui oui mais bien sûr on est
bien d'accord euh de mais de même que
j'ai déjà vu des cabinets de ministres
expliquer alors non pas qu'il voulait
les questions avant mais enfin que quand
même si on pouvait leur expliquer
exactement avant ce qu' allait se passer
et cetera c'était c'était mieux
euh il y a toujours moyen de donner deux
trois trucs et de vous voyez c'estàdire
que je ça ça ne m'étonne pas qu'il
jouent leur partition la c'est la
question c'est est-ce que le journaliste
en
face accepte de rentrer totalement dans
le jeu où est-ce qu'il biaèise voyez
donc là en l'occurrence dans un cadre
comme le vôtre où vous êtes dans une
interview euh vous pouvez pas accepter
ça
bà sinon vous vous privez de l'interview
c'est ça mais sans doute faut-il mieux
se priver de l'interview que d'avoir une
langue de bois absolue ouais voilà c'est
tout comme conseil pour quand même y
aller parce que je on va vous expliquer
rapide he on a on a on a on a shooté
Axel le maire pendant la Loire
renseignement qui voulait pas répondre
au télé comme on a une forte communauté
de hackur de geek derrière nous et qu'on
est fortement en raciné dans cette
guilde et on lui a posé clairement les
choses hein on lui a dit euh nous on va
dire qu'on a essayé de vous parler
méfiez-vous s'il y a 100000 personnes
qui débarquent sur votre compte Twitter
on sera pas responsable quand ils ont vu
nos partenaires ils ont dit oups ils ont
que des partenaires qui ont 2 millions
de visiteurs uniques par mois
c'est compliqué elle a joué la
transparence elle a tenu sa parole dans
les autres ministères c'est compliqué
donc est-ce que vous nous conseillez de
continuer à faire les mercenaires oui
ouais oui bien sûr bien sûr de toute
façon je pense que vous avez une arme
absolue
qui est le caractère immédiatement
mesurable de votre
puissance c'est tout la presse écrite
n'a plus tout à fait ça la la presse
classique quand je dis presse écrite
c'est aussi radio télé et sur des choses
beaucoup moins comment dire beaucoup
moins immédiat que ne peuvent l'être les
réseaux
sociaux donc si le rapport de force
s'inverse il faut pas hésiter à
l'utiliser c'est un rapport de
force formation il faut aller la il faut
aller la chercher la le questionnement
il est il peut-être violent et il doit
l'être parfois donc on peut s'engueuler
encore on peut s'en mettre plein la tête
une vraie joute oratoire mais j'espère
mais j'espère bien le drame aujourd'hui
c'est que la plupart des gens
n'acceptent de venir débattre qu'avec
ceux avec qui ils sont déjà d'accord
vous voudriez débattre avec acrimè ouais
bien sûr tout de suite oui d'accord
bien sûr moi j'ai aucun
problème si vous aviez laissé un conseil
aux jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer sur Internet nous on a le prisme
à moyen terme à long terme on essaie de
détecter les signaux faibles et on
essaie aussi de laisser des
préconisations la jeunesse qui fume des
pétards à 3h du matin et qui regarde des
émissions de
géopolitique un conseil pour les jeunes
générations lis
tucidide vraiment
je je peux vous dire que ça lisez et en
particulier révisez l'histoire antique
l'histoire romaine l'histoire grecque
c'est une c'est une manne pour
comprendre justement ce que c'est
réellement que la géopolitique ce que
c'est que les rapports de force quand
vous lisez dans la guerre du
Péloponèse la façon dont Athène a traité
la la petite île de Mélos qui voulait
rester neutre dans la guerre qui ne
voulait pas euh surtout pas se mêler du
conflit et cathen leur a dit mais
attendez nous on veut pas de neutralité
si vous êtes pas avec nous vous êtes
contre nous et ils ont envahi MOS et ils
ont réduit en esclavage toute la
population mais c'est une explication
absolument extraordinaire du mode de
fonctionnement de
l'impérialisme si vous si vous regardez
le fonctionnement d'Athène la façon dont
ils appliquent et dont ils sont très
fiers d'appliquer en leur sein la
démocratie
mais la façon dont ils traitent leurs
alliés vous comprenez d'abord que ce
sont pas des alliés ce que c'est que
voilà que ce sont pas des alliés mais
des subordonnés et ça vous rappelle un
impérialisme actuel assez marqué et
ensuite ça vous explique pourquoi ça
s'est effondré parce que ça finit par
s'effondrer ouis c'est Goolen royal au
Kedor ça vous fait penser à quoi pardon
la
bravitude c'est ouais ouais
ouais vous avez d'autres choses à nous
poser des questions me poser vous à
votre tour
HM des questions oui oui bien sûr
euh vous êtes non journaliste et vous
êtes extrêmement critique sur le
journalisme ce que je comprends
parfaitement euh et je le suis
aussi est-ce que pour autant
euh vous estimez qu'il faut que la
presse et les médias tels qu'ils
existent disparaissent ouis
oui à 100 % etce que vous CZ je vais
délayer je vais délayer la la
réponse quand vous avez trahi la
confiance de
quelqu'un jamais vous ne pouvez revenir
en arrière
oui ça je crois que c'est vrai je crois
que c'est vrai en même temps euh et et
je pense d'ailleurs que il y a moyen
aujourd'hui en tout cas de réfléchir à
une façon de développer sur le net
l'ensemble de ce qu'apporte je disais
tout à l'heure l'URE que je pense que
pour l'instant le travail que fait le le
journalisme de presse écrite notamment
on le trouve pas sur le net sous la même
forme c'est vrai je le pense pour autant
je pense qu'à terme de toute façon ça se
passera on est dans une phase de
transition et ce que moi je viens
chercher dans la presse je crois que ça
peut surgir aussi de diverses manières
sur le
net simplement
c'est un modèle économique c'est une
question de modèle économique comment on
arrive à faire vivre ça pour l'instant
malheureusement il faut beaucoup
d'argent pour payer un type qui a faire
un reportage au long
cours voilà c'est ça ne je ne sais pas
si on a trouvé la solution pour que ce
soit rentable non vous avez d'autres
questions à nous poser
h j'imagine que vous n'êtes
pas vous je je pense que nous n'avons
pas la même
culture comment dire je très honnêtement
je n'ai pas une culture des nouvelles
technologies je n'ai pas je
et pour l'instant je n'ai pas eu le
temps de m'intéresser suffisamment à ces
problématique et à toutes ces et à toute
l'implication que ça peut avoir sur les
questions de notamment de journalisme
d'investigation enfin c'est pas que ça
m'intéresse pas je je m'y suis intéressé
mais pas pas autant que je le voudrais
c'estàd que je ne serai jamais
pérempptoire sur ces questions là parce
que j'estime que il y a des choses
encore des choses que je ne maîtrise pas
suffisamment j'ai une culture trop
classique pour ça mais je sais pas si ça
t encore c'est quoi une culture trop
classique on va dire que je suis
quelqu'un de
l'écrit mais véritablement quelqu'un qui
va s'intéresser spontanément au récit à
à la pensée
à à
l'idéologie voilà je
suis je suis profondément je pense
imprégé de culture littéraire et de
culture historique et c'est pour ça que
je pense que j'ai envie d'ouvrir le
comité
Orwell à des journalistes qui auront un
autre type de culture que la mienne
c'est-à-dire qui seront bien plus au
fait de des modes de
fonctionnement des réseaux sociaux vous
voyez tout ce qui concerne le hacking
par exemple est quelque chose qui
m'échappe je ne sais pas comment ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne très simplement
oui oui bien sûr
mais les choses ne sont jamais simples
j'aime comprendre j'aime comprendre
jusqu'au bout donc quand on cherche à
comprendre ça n'est jamais simple ou
quand on est passionné c'est toujours
simple voilà ah j'ai peut-être une
petite question encore je pas
alors l'information de très haute
qualité dont vous rêvez vous que vous
professez une information qui fait appel
à l'intelligence des gens comment
peut-elle être mise en place dans un
système où les médias sont à but
lucratif et en
concurrence c'est toute l'ambivalence
bien sûr c'està-dire que ce je le disais
tout à l'heure ce son ce sont des
entreprises mais ce ne sont pas des
entreprises comme les autres donc ça ne
peut fonctionner que dans un système où
il y a un public éclairé qui a envie de
payer pour cette information pour cette
cette réflexion de qualité y a-t-il
encore aujourd'hui un public de lecteur
non mais Natacha non le principe de
catatonie intellectuelle c'est simple
vous mettez quelqu'un sous pression vous
le le harceler de peine et de mots crise
financière perte de boulot problème à
l'école terrorisme crise nucléaire
pollution pesticid et on en passe des
meilleurs qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a
un effet de repli tout le monde le sait
du MO les gens déjà éclairés le savent
oui bien sûr et et quand on extrapole le
on extrapole le raisonnement on sait
pertinemment que ce sont des belles
paroles de de dire que on on ne peut
avoir qu'un qu'un public éclairé mais il
y en a de moins en moins la dynamique
viens de dire nous nous on a la
dynamique de lâcher prise c'est-à-dire
que on vous laisse encore une chance
vous les journalistes de de laver votre
honneur de laver votre profession mais
le cercle le cercle Orwell pour nous le
comité
Orwell au départ on l'a un peu mal pris
que vous appeliez comme ça parce que
c'est c'est c'est lourd de symbolique
pour nous et on s'est dit quand même ils
essayent de survivre ils essayent de se
réveiller alors c'est peut-être pas tous
les journaliste et que il y en a une qui
a décidé de sortir parce qu'elle a une
paire de baloche un peu plus endurcie
que la maageure partie de sa
caste et on vous laisse faire on va
peut-être essayer de vous aider du moins
de regarder la profession journalistique
avec un peu plus de bienveillance mais
après vous serez relégué définitivement
avec les politiques les lobbyiste et
ainsi de suite c'estàdire que vous allez
devenir la
cible vraiment de gens pertinents sur
l'outil numérique ça risque de très mal
se passer donc battez-vous
oui battez-vous
mais d'abord je vais vous dire une chose
je ne me suis jamais senti appartenir à
aucune caste ou aucune
corporation je n'ai pas l'esprit de cast
vous n'avez jamais acheté de voiture
avec votre carte presse non d'accord euh
non pourquoi on achète une voiture avec
une carte de presse estce que vous
pouvez acheter une machine à laver aussi
avec une carte de
presse non alors je vous conseille je
vous conseille un truc je do vraiment
être très con ouais vous vous appelez
vous appelez vous êtes journaliste vous
avez une carte de presse hop il une
réduction ah ben je savais pas vous
voyez vous me la prenez c'est sympa on
peut en profiter ah bah ouais ouais si
vous voulez mais je non vous voyz j'ai
j'ai loupé des trucs ouais ouais c'est
comme quoi les journalistes sont quand
même parfois les moins bien informés non
non non sérieusement sérieusement don
non non je je sais pas je dois avoir
d'abord un vieux fond
d'éducation tout
ça moi j'ai une éducation un peu gen
séniste il y a des trucs qui se font pas
bon bah voilà non non c'est et et
honnêtement je n'ai jamais eu l'esprit
de corps j'ai été prof aussi j'étais pas
plus corporatiste côté prof que côté
journaliste voilà je sens je ne me sens
absolument pas comptable de ce que font
les journalistes en général c'est bien
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir
comment moi je vais essayer de faire mon
boulot à peu près honnêtement et de
faire en sorte vous au Figaro quand même
ah je suis plus journaliste au Figaro je
suis je suis chroniqueuse ex
je suis pas salarié de la de la
rédaction je d'ailleurs j'y mets pas les
pieds parce que je ne suis pas
journaliste au Figaro je l'ai été
pendant 3 ans sur les questions
d'éducation le comité Orel on vous a
objecté que vous travaillez pour un
marchand d'armes c'est quoi votre avis
là-dessus ben mon avis c'est que
malheureusement aujourd'hui en effet une
bonne partie des médias appartiennent à
des grands groupes industriels et en
particulier des groupes des groupes qui
vendent des armes plutôt que de
m'objecter Le Figaro on aurait pu
m'objecter d'ailleurs eurin là
d'ailleurs je suis pas plus salarié
enfin je suis pas plus en CDI mais je
suis salarié là pour le coup euh
simplement j'ai commencé mon travail de
journaliste à Marianne qui est un des
rares journaux indépendants et j'en ai
gardé l'idée que en effet dans un monde
idéal il fallait aller vers les médias
qui étaient les plus indépendants et que
ça permettait plus de liberté pour
autant d'abord c'est que quand même à
Marianne que je me suis fait placardiser
pour mes idées voilà à partir du départ
de Jean-François
canne le Journal s'est recentré vers
quelque chose de gentiment gauche bien
pensante social-démocrate donc j'avais
plus ma place voilà alors que au Figaro
j'ai pu quand j'étais journaliste sur
les questions d'éducation dire tout le
mal que je pensais des lois
Châtel je me suis jamais fait taper sur
les doigts la seule fois où je me suis
fait taper sur les doigts c'était
c'était quand j'étais invité comme
éditorialiste sur les plateaux de
télévision moi qui n'était que rubricard
d'éducation ce qui fait partie des
hasards de la vie bon ça s'est trouvé
comme ça
et taper sur les doigts ça s'est
manifesté comment taper sur les doigts
non c'était un coup de
téléphone d'un supérieur hiérarchique me
disant écoute la prochaine fois essaie
d'y aller molo comment il s'appelle
je ne balance pas les supérieurs
hiérarchiques d'accord non ça j'estime
que ça se fait pas non voilà mais il
suffit de savoir que c'est un supérieur
hiérarchique au Figaro mais on sait
jamais si on tombe sur le nom sur
Internet on pourra peut-être essayer de
lui envoyer un petit mail le remercier
non et vous savez sur quel sujet c'était
la guerre en Libye ah tiens pour changer
parce que je m'étais j'étais sur le
plateau de Thierry Ardisson ouais et que
j'avais j'étais là pour parler
bioéthique parce que l'invité c'était
René Friedman ouis et ils avaient invité
deux personnalités amies de René
Friedman donc l'abbé de La moranda et
Bernard couchner et il se trouve que la
discussion arrive c'était pile au moment
où la France commençait à intervenir en
Libye et Bernard a sorti son sac de riz
ben voilà et il nous a expliqué que
c'était merveilleux et qu'on allait
sauver le monde ouais la démocratie pour
les petites filles voilà et là je lu ai
dit écoutez ça me paraît quand même un
petit peu présomptueux enfin excusez-moi
on a fait quelques anneries en Irak on
n'est peut-être pas obligé non plus de
recommencer et de recommencer en étant
persuadé que cette fois-ci ça va être
merveilleux donc le minimum c'est
d'avoir un tout petit peu de de prudence
et là ils m'ont tous regardé en se
demandant d'où je sortais c'est c'était
il y avait un côté comment dire j'avais
fait intrusion dans un dîner de gamb
bien et qui l'a invité celle-là
d'ailleurs ça a été la question après
mais pourquoi mais mais pourquoi mais il
faut inviter des gens sérieux quand même
un petit peu voilà mais ça m'a valu de
me retrouver à On n'est pas couché
puisque Catherine Barma était devant sa
télé il s'est dit tiens au moins elle
elle sait tenir tête voilà c'était c'est
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à On
n'est pas couché est-ce que vous avez
déjà réussi à faire partir un
invité par exemple jacqu etal je l'ai
pas eu On n'est pas couché jacquesatalie
ah oui non non non non j'ai mais
jacquetali il part souvent ouaisis c'est
facile de le faire partir d'expérience
les gens qui quittent les plateaux sont
des multirécidivistes oui donc il y a
pas grande gloire à faire un plate fier
non moi le seul qui soit parti quand
j'étais en é pas couché c'est Christophe
onelat oui oui il pas et je n'en ai
conçu j'aimais beaucoup son le trésor il
était très marrant oui mais bon c'est et
c'est même ça a même été très négatif
parce que
ça c'était volon faire de sa part
c'était une façon de mettre ça de se
mettre en scène et
euh du coup ça a donné l'impression je
venais d'arriver On n'est pas couché ça
ça a donné l'impression à beaucoup de
gens que évidemment cette émission était
là pour faire du clash et que j'étais
moi-même évidemment une partie de ce
système supp et donc ça a décrédibilisé
totalement mon travail et j'ai été
obligé de ramer après pour essayer de
montrer que mon but n'était pas de faire
du clash mais de débattre et de essayer
de penser les problèmes de façon un peu
pertinente et honnête si vous aviez une
équipe une Task Force de de la matière
grise à former vous metiez qui
dedans bah des gens que vous connaissez
pas forcément allez allez
euh une équipe à formmer mais enfin ça
dépend pour former pour faire quoi
l'agence tourisque de l'information
agence tourisque de l'information donc
Hannibal Hannibal qui qui assumerait
Hannibal oh écoutez je sais pas il y a
des il y a quelques personnes que je
respecte beaucoup parmi les journalistes
aujourd'hui et que pas forcément oui
pourquoi pas et puis vous voyez
quelqu'un comme Vanessa Ratinier par
exemple qui a travaillé avec Pierre
Péant sur sur le Qatar et quelqu'un que
je respecte et que j'apprécie c'est ce
genre de personne que j'aurais envie de
de faire travailler si je pouvais me
choisir une équipe celle que
vous impossible de la faire entrer dans
l'équipe laquelle
c'est vous avez quelques heures ouais
ouais commener par un N ça nous
suffira d'accord vous savez j'en ai
croisé j'en ai croisé tellement il faut
nous donner des cibles des cibles mais
je fonctionne pas par cible d'accord
c'està-dire que c'est pas une question
de de l'acheter c'est que je me fous des
personnes c'est pour moi c'est
totalement un
mais le vecteur d'idée c'est c'est c'est
le principe le principe c'est la
personne cert le messager n rien par
rapport au message quand vous êtes dans
un théâtre d'opération il faut savoir
aussi neutraliser les vecteurs vous vous
faites vous les journalistes vous faites
neutraliser d' d'une façon acceptée ou
du moins la plupart se font neutraliser
ou consciemment ou avec leur
aval nous on neutralise les vecteurs
c'est c'est notre PL dire quand vous
avez un journaliste qui est vecteur
d'une mauvaise information ou d'une
information qui est biaisée on commence
à s'intéresser au journalistes et on
court circuit de ce vecteur là vous avez
pas un petit nom à nous dire celui qui
je pense que vous les connaissez aussi
bien que
moi non non non
c'est honnêtement c'est pas vous voyez
moi ma façon de
fonctionner mais c'est une façon aussi
c'est c'est un tort sans doute très
individuel parce que c'est peut-être
parce que j'ai un parcours un peu à part
ma façon de fonctionner ça a toujours
été de faire mon boulot du mieux que je
pouvais en suivant une ligne une ligne
idéologique en défendant les les valeurs
qui sont les miennes les idées qui sont
les miennes il se trouve que j'ai eu le
bol de profiter d'un système audiovisuel
qui a besoin de mettre des femmes voilà
je suis bénéficiaire de la
discrimination positive ouais de la
discrimination positive de la parité
contre la discrimination positive moi je
suis contre la discrimination
positive je pense que il est nécessaire
que l'ensemble de la population soit
représenter dans les médias comme
ailleurs mais que c'est pas par la
discrimination positive qu'il faut le
faire vous vous assurez vous vous
assumez vos vos
opinion vous avez une garde rapprochée
contre les
terroristes non pourquoi est-ce que vous
comprenez que certains journaliste soit
protégé par
l'État écoutez surtout en ce moment s
ils ont reçu des menaces de mort oui il
me semble que ça enfin je sais pas je
comprends que est-ce que vous pensez que
ce dispositif est
suffisamment on va dire puissant pour
protéger nos journalistes ceux qui font
leur
boulot estce qu'on a mis suffisment de
moyens pour protéger les femmes
journalistes non non je enfin je sais je
je pense que on a vu que tout dispositif
de protection
de toute façon avait peu de chance
de d'être de faire face à des à des
attaques de personnes déterminé
mais je pense
que
c'est la enfin comment dire ça dépend de
quelle de quelle menace vous parle de
quel type de menace et de quel alors
nous on fait de la veille aussi sur les
terroristes et on voit beaucoup de Rais
s'activé sur les femmes
journalistes et on trouve que on met pas
assez le paquet pour les protéger et on
en profite pour faire passer un
message voilà
oui c'est possible je pense
que on va on vaend encore en manger pour
30 ans vous savez ah ça c'est ça c'est
sûr c'est sûr qu'on parle de on parle de
problème de très long
terme mais je crains malheureusement que
la protection même si elle est
nécessaire ne soit jamais totalement
suffisante vous vous vous savez manier
une arme non mais comme je suis
quelqu'un d'extrêmement
euh comment dire certains diraient
anxieux d'autres peut-être lucide et que
je suis en pleine réflexion sur
réflexion limite fascination sur le
survivalisme pouri des tendan pourquoi
fascination
non c'est une façon de parler je
plaisante mais c'est mais je j'ai
toujours euh été très intéressé par les
réflexions qui essaent d'anticiper ce
que peut-être la justement la la chute
d'une civilisation ne serait-ce que
parce que j'ai conscience que c'est
parfaitement possible que ça peut
arriver et donc il m'arrive de temps en
temps de me dire que euh je j'aimerais
savoir manier une arme
et que c'est quelque chose de
d'extrêmement utile en plus quand
j'étais petite mon père m'emmenait il
avait dans un cadre légal mais bien
entendu mais j'ai très petite j'ai
arpenté les clubs de Tir pour tirer à la
carabine quel était votre calibre
préféré à l'époque j'étais petite je
j'avais 6
ans Natacha Polonie merci et plir de
vous revoir sur notre chaîne YouTube
mais merci de votre invitation merci
beaucoup
[Musique]